>> EVERY TEAM IS ONLY AS GOOD AS
ITS LEADER.
WE SEE IT IN SPORTS ALL THE
TIME.
LEGENDARY COACHES LIKE NICK
SABAN AND BILL BELICHICK GREAT
CHAMPION NOT ONLY BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THE X'S AND O'S BECAUSE
THEY KNOW HOW TO MOTIVATE YOU.
HOW TO MAKE YOU BELIEVE YOU ARE
BIGGER THAN YOURSELF.
THAT YOU CAN BEAT ANY CHALLENGE
NO MATTER THE ODDS.
LIKE WHAT HERB BROOKS DID BEFORE
THE 1980 OLYMPIC HOCKEY GAME
BETWEEN THE UNDER DOG THE UNITED
STATES AND THE HEAVILY FAVORED
THE SOVIETS.
>> THIS IS YOUR TIME.
DELIVER TIME IS DONE.
IT'S OVER.
I'M SICK AND TIRED OF HEARING
ABOUT WHAT A GREAT HOCKEY TEAM
THE SOVIETS HAVE.
SCREW EM.
THIS IS YOUR TIME.
>> Jesse: THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
DISNEY VERSION.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
THAT SPEECH THE UNITED STATES
SHOCKED THE WORLD BECAUSE THEY
WERE LED TO BELIEVE THAT THEY
COULD.
LEADERSHIP COMES FROM DEEP
INSIDE.
AND IT'S NOT EXCLUSIVE TO A
POLITICAL PARTY.
EACH DEMOCRATS HAVE FOLLOWED
PROUD RESPECTIVE LEADERS PUT
AMERICA FIRST MEN LIKE JOHN F.
KENNEDY WHO EXEMPLIFIED
EVERYTHING RIGHT WITH OUR
COUNTRY.
WHO REPRESENTED US ON THE WORLD
STAGE AND KNEW HOW TO DELIVER A
MESSAGE.
>> SO, MY FELLOW AMERICANS, ASK
NOT WHAT YOUR COUNTRY CAN DO FOR
YOU, ASK WHAT YOU CAN DO TORE
YOUR COUNTRY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jesse: THE MESSAGE IS
SELFLESSNESS AND PATRIOTISM.
ARE WE SURE JFK WAS A DEMOCRAT?
LOOK HOW FAR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS FALLEN SINCE THEN.
TODAY NANCY PELOSI SENT SHOCK
WAVES THROUGH D.C. WHEN SHE
ANNOUNCED SHE WAS CALLING IT
QUITS ON HOUSE LEADERSHIP.
>> WOE MUST MOVE BOLDLY INTO THE
FUTURE.
GROUNDED BY THE PRINCIPLES THAT
HAVE PROPELLED US THIS FAR AND
OPEN TO FRESH POSSIBILITIES FOR
THE FUTURE.
AND WITH GREAT CONFIDENCE IN OUR
CAUCUS, I WILL NOT SEEK
RE-ELECTION TO DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP IN THE NEXT
CONGRESSMAN FOR ME THE HOUR HAS
COME FOR A NEW GENERATION TO
LEAD THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THAT
I SO DEEPLY RESIDENCE.
>> Jesse: PELOSI'S VICE LIKE
GRIP TON DEMOCRATIC PARTY POWER
LOOKS TO BE COMING TO AN END.
BUT IT'S BEEN A HELL OF A RIDE
FOR NANC.
SEE COULD EXERCISE THE DUTIES OF
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
ENOUGH TO THAT SHE IS GONE,
WHAT'S NEXT?
COULD IT BE MICHELLE OBAMA?
WE CRASHED HER BOOK TOUR TO ASK
PEOPLE WHAT THEY TOUT ABOUT HER
AND WE WILL HAVE MORE OF THAT
LATER ON IN THE SHOW.
BUT, WE KNOW IT WON'T BE JIM
CLYBURN OR CHUCK SCHUMER.
NO ONE IS GOING TO FOLLOW THEM.
THEIR TIME HAS COME AND GONE.
JOE BIDEN HAS NOTHING LEFT IN
THE TANK.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW IF IS HE
GOING TO RUN AGAIN IN '24.
MEMBERS OF HIS OWN PARTY ARE
ALREADY DOUBTING HIS FITNESS.
SO, IN THEIR QUEST FOR A NEW
KING, IT LOOKS LIKE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TURNING TO THEIR
OLD PLAYBOOK THE SAME ONE THAT
GOT JOE BIDEN ELECTED IN THE
FIRST PLACE THE BASEMENT PLAN.
DEMOCRATS KNOW THEY NEED KEEP
THEIR CANDIDATES OUT OF SIGHT
AND OUT OF MIND BECAUSE THE MORE
PEOPLE SEE AND HEAR THEM THE
LESS THEY LIKE.
NATURALLY.
THAT MEANS JOHN FETTERMAN JUST
MOVED TO THE TOP OF THE
DEMOCRATS' LIST FOR 2024.
HE SPENT HALF HIS CAMPAIGN
HIDING OUT, STEERING CLEAR OF
THE PRESS.
THE LEFT IS WASTE NOTHING TIME
ANOINTING HIM AS THE NEXT
PRESIDENT.
>> FETTERMAN AS A NOMINEE AT
SOME POINT FOR PRESIDENT, I KNOW
THERE IS SOME VARIABLES,
OBVIOUSLY, WHAT HE DID IN THE
SUPER RED DEEP RED PARTS OF
PENNSYLVANIA IN THE WAY THAT HE
RAN AHEAD OF BIDEN AS YOU WERE
SAYING, RAN AHEAD OF TRUMP, IT
MAKES YOU WONDER ABOUT HIS
FUTURE.
>> Jesse: FETTERMAN AS A NOMINEE
AT SOME POINT FOR PRESIDENT?
I KNOW THERE IS SOME VARIABLES.
OBVIOUSLY.
I MEAN, WHAT HE DID IN THE SUPER
DEEP RED.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THESE PEOPLE?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT.
IT WASN'T JUST MSNBC JUMPING THE
GUN.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" RAN A PIECE
CALLING FOR THE REST OF THE
DEMOCRATS TO FOLLOW FETTERMAN'S
LEAD.
EVEN DOWN TO THE BASKETBALL
SHORTS.
THEY THINK FETTERMAN'S SLOPPY
APPEARANCE IS ACTUALLY AN
ADVANTAGE WITH THE POLITICAL OP.
SAYING YOU CAN'T DISCOUNT THE
LOOK.
HIS SIGNATURE OUTFIT IS A
CARHARTT HOODIE AND CARGO
SHORTS.
IT'S NOT JUST THE FACT THAT HIS
WARDROBE LOOKS LIKE IS HE GOING
OUT TO 7-ELEVEN WITHOUT A
SHOWER, ACCORDING TO THE
"TIMES," FETTERMAN'S BIGGEST
STRENGTH IS THAT HE IS A VICTIM.
SAYING THIS.
HE DEMONSTRATED VULNERABILITY.
THIS KIND OF MALE IS NOT
SUPPOSED TO WEAK OR FALL DOWN.
HE ADMITTED HE WAS NOT IN
CONTROL AND LIFTED UP
VULNERABILITY AS A STRENGTH.
WE ALL KNOW THE LEFT LOVES A
GOOD VICTIM.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALL ABOUT
CONTROLLING YOU AND WHO IS
EASIER TO CONTROL THAN A VICTIM?
THAT'S WHY THEY USE KIDS OR
MINORITIES, THEY SAY.
AND THE IMPARITY AND PROPS.
YOU CAN'T ATTACK THEM OR YOU
COME OFF AS A BULLY.
>> OZ WOULD COME OFF AS A BULLY.
WE SHOULD STRESS THAT
FETTERMAN'S DOCTOR SAID HE WILL
MAKE A FULL RECOVERY.
OZ CAME OFF AS A BULLY.
DEBATES USUALLY DON'T MATTER
THAT MUCH.
THIS ONE MIGHT.
>> IT WAS REALLY STRANGE TO ME
THAT HE CHOSE TO BULLY A STROKE
VICTIM.
>> YEAH,.
>> LIKE HE OBVIOUSLY WAS
BULLYING HIM.
>> ANY DIFFERENCE IN WHAT THEY
DID WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
MAY MADE THE TEENAGE GIRL THE
FACE OF THE MOVEMENT.
ANY TIME YOU CRITICIZE HER YOU
LOOK LIKE A JERK.
THIS ISN'T SYMPATHY WHAT THEY
ARE DOING TO FETTERMAN IS DOWN
RIGHT COOL.
SENATOR IS ONE OF THE MOST
STRESSFUL JOBS CAN YOU HAVE AND
STRESS LEADS TO STROKES.
THEY ARE SETTING HIM UP FOR A
DISASTER.
FOR BORDERS THERE IS NO
BOUNDARY.
THESE ARE RELENTLESS.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, MR. PRESIDENT.
[SHOUTING]
>> I HAVE NO COMMENT.
I HAVE WILL BE GRATEFUL TO BE
HOME.
GRATEFUL TO BE BACK WITH ALL MY
COLLEAGUES AND I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO GET A LOT DONE.
[SHOUTING QUESTIONS]
>> Jesse: WILL FETTERMAN BE ABLE
TO HANDLE LIVE QUESTIONS BIDEN
COULDN'T HE CAN'T HANDLE
REPORTERS HOW DO YOU KNOW HE
UNDERSTANDS THE ISSUES.
>> WE NIGHT TO FIGHT ABOUT
INFLATION.
>> THERE IS THAT 2018 INTERVIEW
THAT YOU SAID, QUOTE, I DON'T
SUPPORT FRACKING AT ALL.
HOW DO YOU SQUARE THE TWO?
>> OH, I DO SUPPORT FRACKING
AND -- I DON'T -- I DON'T -- I
SUPPORT FRACKING.
AND I STAND -- AND I DO SUPPORT
FRACKING.
>> Jesse: DOES ANYBODY EVEN
BELIEVE FETTERMAN KNOW WHAT IS
FRACKING IS?
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
AND AREN'T SENATORS SUPPOSED TO
ACTUALLY WRITE LEGISLATION.
I MEAN, IT'S MOSTLY WRITTEN BY
LOBBYISTS.
COME ON, AT LEAST YOU GOT TO
PRETEND TO GET INVOLVED IT.
LOOKS LIKE FETTERMAN IS THE PROP
AND BISEXUAL BRAZILIAN SPY WIFE
IN CHARGE.
SHE IS ALREADY CROPPING HIM OUT
OF PICTURES, HOW LONG BEFORE SHE
PUSHES HIM OUT OF OFFICE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ABANDONED THE
GOAL OF PERSUADING VOTERS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DEBATE IDEAS
ANYMORE.
THEY ARE JUST PUSHING
VICTIMIZATION THEY CAN
MANIPULATE AND HIDE AND LET THE
MEDIA CAMPAIGN FOR THEM AND LET
THE LOBBYISTS DO THE REST.
THEY GOT AWAY WITH IT IN 2020
HIDING BIDEN IN THE BASEMENT
RUNNING HIS CAMPAIGN FOR HIM.
WE SAW IT IN ARIZONA THIS YEAR.
REMEMBER KATIE HOBBS, WON THE
GOVERNORSHIP SUPPOSEDLY WITHOUT
EVER STEPPING ON A DEBATE STAGE?
AND NOW THEY ARE SETTING THE
STAPLING FOR FETTERMAN TO DO IT
ALL OVER AGAIN IN '24 OR '28.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, BIG TECH AND WALL STREET
ON YOUR SIDE, YOU DON'T REALLY
HAVE TO RUN A TRADITIONAL
CAMPAIGN.
YOU JUST DESTROY YOUR OPPONENT
AND HIDE IN THE BASEMENT.
THAT'S THE NEW GAME PLAN.
THE PARTY OF JFK IS